[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAN YANEHIRO:
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to a special chat
with a star in the food world,
Deepa Thomas.
How about an applause here?
Let's hear it.
Come on, Google people.
DEEPA THOMAS: Thank you.
JAN YANEHIRO: Deepa Thomas--
This is her cookbook,
"Deepa's Secrets."
And today here at the
188 Embarcadero Campus,
you are sampling her cuisine.
So thank you.
Oh.
Right here.
The chefs right here,
thank you for [INAUDIBLE]..
So I'm Jan Yanehiro.
I'm a longtime broadcaster
in San Francisco,
and I have the honor of
interviewing the star Deepa
Thomas.
And here's what
we'd like to do--
I've prepared some
questions, Deepa.
Thank you very much.
We've got the book.
We've got slides going on.
We've got a studio audience.
I will open it up for Q&A
from the studio audience,
and we will adjourn--
because I know this
is lunch hour--
we're going to adjourn
by 1:00 o'clock.
So everybody good
with that plan?
OK.
Here we go.
Thank you for making time.
OK.
First question-- love the
book, and I hope all of you
get a copy of the book here
and all Google campuses.
It is a beautiful
book, and I want
to say that every single
photograph in this book--
the food was cooked by
Deepa, photographed by Deepa,
and no artificial light.
It's all natural lighting.
So when you see pictures
like this in the book--
Mike, can you see this close up?
I mean, it's just
stunning and beautiful.
And she also wraps the
book up with history,
growing up in India, meeting
the most eligible man in India,
and marrying him.
So here we go.
Third printing, congratulations.
DEEPA THOMAS: Thank you.
JAN YANEHIRO: But looking
back, you studied journalism
and political science at
India, came to the US,
did a textile company--
congratulations--
and here you are now
writing a book on
Indian cuisine.
What made the transfer from
textiles to food, Deepa.
JAN YANEHIRO: Well, first
of all Jan Yanehiro, people.
How lucky am I to have the
Hall of Fame broadcaster
herself talking about my book,
my first little experiment
in cuisine?
But to answer your
question, you probably
guessed it's not just
the book in third print.
I've been in third or
fourth or fifth print
because I think you have to show
up and meet the opportunities
as they appear and put one
foot in front of the other
and think about how you can make
your talents useful to others.
And this came about with
discovering that my husband was
a type 2 diabetic.
Of course, he looks
like Omar Sharif,
but that didn't mean he
didn't have diabetes.
And we didn't know
how to manage this
except with insulin shots,
which he was on for 10 years.
And when I finally
retired from my business,
I thought, well what happens
if I looked at food--
[? dinner-- ?] food as art.
And definitely we eat with
our eyes first, right?
You'd agree.
If you see it and it looks
beautiful, you want to try it.
So I thought, is there a way
I could trick my husband--
like a good wife--
trick him into eating healthy.
Because if I told this rice
bowl kid growing up in the south
of India-- rice was the staple--
oh, you know what?
I'm just going to take rice out.
I'm going to take bread out.
I'm going to take all
the white carbs out.
He's have gone shopping
for another wife.
So I had to trick him into it.
And the rule I apply,
for those of you
who like to cook and understand,
cooking in layers of flavor--
you can bump up the flavor if
you're taking something out.
So if I took out a
bad ingredient that
causes sugar spikes and weight
gain, like a refined carb,
I would bump it up with
an Indian gremolata
or caramelized
shallots at the end.
And I like to think you
can redo and recover
from any mistake in cooking--
and I've made my fair share
of them-- except burnt garlic.
Because then you just throw
it out and start again.
JAN YANEHIRO: That
was the start.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yes.
JAN YANEHIRO: And to be honest,
in fact, with your cooking
you lost 20 pounds yourself.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yes.
JAN YANEHIRO: Your
husband lost weight,
and in fact, he is off of
insulin shots with Deepa's
cooking from this book.
So let that be a
lesson to all of us.
Now, moving on.
It appears to me that Indian
cuisine is having its moment
here in the US.
It's become very popular.
We're all flocking to all
the Indian restaurants.
Why do you think that
Indian food is now having
its moment here in the US?
DEEPA THOMAS: That's
a great question.
In fact, there was a
story in the local papers
about Indian food on the
rise, and they actually
asked me to say something.
And I shot my mouth
off, as is my want.
And what I think is happening is
borderless cuisine is probably
what we need to focus on.
Indian food has been very
much an exotic cuisine
for a lot of years.
Now it's slowly moving
into mainstream,
like before it, Italian
food did or Chinese food.
I think this is the melting
pot, not just of people
from different
parts of the world,
but of techniques and flavors.
And when you can
blend the flavors
without creating
a flavor model--
I'm not a big proponent
of fusion cuisine
because you don't know
what the heck it is.
But if you can have,
like music, clear
notes even if it's borrowed
from other cuisines.
So Indian food is coming into
the mainstream for that reason
maybe.
It's always been the high
flavor ticket, right?
But now people are getting
aware of its health benefits.
JAN YANEHIRO: Correct.
And the health benefits-- do you
think it comes from the spices
or how it's cooked,
the ingredients?
DEEPA THOMAS: Yeah.
You know, it's really an irony
that India 3,000 years ago knew
that food is medicine, that
when your diet is right,
medicine is of no need.
And when diet is wrong,
medicine is of no use.
This is 3,000 years
ago, Ayurveda, India.
Well then how can India be the
diabetic capital of the world?
Isn't it interesting?
JAN YANEHIRO: Yes.
DEEPA THOMAS: So
what happened is
what we did to ingredients
in the course of time
from 3,000 years to now.
We treated food in
such a manner that it
would stay stable on supermarket
shelves and in warehouses.
And in the process, we overly
refined all the ingredients.
So as Michael Pollan
says, eat food
that your grandmother
would recognize.
She wouldn't recognize
wheat today, for instance.
And India knows,
but they don't know
how to handle modern,
industrialized ingredients.
But it knows that all disease
starts in the inflammation that
begins in the gut.
And all disease--
not some disease--
inclusive of type 2 diabetes,
but not limited to it.
So Indian ingredients from
the seeds to the spices
were really a focus of the
old Ayurvedic practitioners
on how to reduce inflammation
while bumping up flavor.
So that's really key.
And what I'm trying to do is
make everything old new again.
It's not that I invented
this way of cooking,
but I'm shining a
light on what is
incredibly anti-inflammatory
about Indian seeds and spices.
And so even if you're
cooking Italian food,
throw some Indians
spices in there.
JAN YANEHIRO: It's healthier.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yes, yes.
JAN YANEHIRO: So you talk a
lot about new Indian cuisine.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yes.
JAN YANEHIRO: Tell
the audience what you
mean by the new Indian cuisine.
DEEPA THOMAS: Well, I'm
an incurable brand geek.
So I had to differentiate
from Indian cuisine
at large and new Indian cooking.
So what is the difference?
Traditional Indian
food we all know
is flavorful and
exciting and exotic.
JAN YANEHIRO: Spicy and curried.
DEEPA THOMAS: And exotic,
if you're not from India
I suppose.
But it's also high in carbs,
very high in refined carbs.
It's incredibly labor intensive.
So you ask what
new Indian cuisine
is-- it's exactly the opposite.
It's less labor, higher flavor,
healthier, lots of shortcuts--
I call them secrets--
and I think that's the
positioning I'd like to take.
It just shines a light on
all that is potentially
good about Indian cuisine.
JAN YANEHIRO: And I think
that's why it's so popular.
But in on your book--
here's a cover everybody--
it says, "Slow Carb."
You know, we hear about
this, but I'm just
going to ask for
everybody in the audience
and across the Google campuses.
Tell us slow carbs--
what is slow carb?
What is it?
DEEPA THOMAS: Well, we can
contrast it with low carb.
Low carb cuts carb across the
board, that all carbs are bad
is the approach in low carb.
I don't believe that to be true.
I think taking the thesis
what we do to a carb
is what makes it bad.
So refining it to one
inch of death is bad.
And the whiter something is--
I'm sorry white people--
you got to look at it again.
But slow carb is closer
to the grain itself.
So complex grains that
haven't been processed,
that make the body work to
be absorbed, higher fiber.
And so the longer a food
takes to be digested,
the better it is for you
as a simple principle.
The quicker it is
to be digested--
like sugar itself or white
carbs, potatoes, rice, flour--
it converts very
quickly to sugar.
And all foods convert to
energy, sugar, energy.
But when it's quickly
converted, it is stored as fat.
So that's the big difference
between slow carb.
You're really focusing on
low glycemic index of foods.
That is how quickly or slowly
food converts to sugar.
JAN YANEHIRO: So whenever
I talk to a chef,
I always say, well, what's
your background, your mother,
your grandmother, or
some your father cook?
I see some people
nodding their heads.
But I've read
Deepa's book, and she
didn't cook as a young girl.
And in fact, she learned to cook
when she came here to the US.
And in fact, she talks about
how she burnt her first meal
for her husband.
Burnt it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAN YANEHIRO: They
had to go get pizza.
But let's talk a
little bit about what
did you learned
growing up in India.
In fact, one of your
grandparents did milk cows.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yes.
JAN YANEHIRO: But
you didn't grow up
with going into the kitchen and
learning everything and trying
everything.
Tell us about that.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yeah.
So I thought everyone grew
up with kitchen stuff, which
is another thing
about Indian cooking.
It's so high in labor
because it was easier
to have people help
you in the kitchen.
Well, when I came to Stanford
campus as a young bride,
I rang the bell and no one came.
So good luck.
Get up and do it yourself.
So it was necessity.
And when the kids
were growing up--
and Suneil will attest to this--
if I got food on the table,
it was considered a win.
It didn't matter what it was.
Just food on the table.
But as we looked at
how we will-- you know,
we were becoming successful.
It's the immigrant dream.
Thampy and I probably
overshot the mark
in all the hopes and dreams
we had to be successful.
But the price we
paid was completely
neglecting our own selves,
not thinking about nutrition
or exercise or well-being.
It was just survival.
You've got to make it.
There's no safety net under you.
So if you're in that
kind of a mindset,
cooking becomes a burden.
But if you start to pay
attention to the one thing you
have in life,
which is your life,
and you start to think about
H-O-L-E's that never get filled
with food, I think it took me--
I'm a very slow learner, as
you've probably guessed by now,
but it took me the better
part of half a century
to really get there.
So I had a very adversarial
relationship with food.
And I don't know how many
people in this room would relate
or across the campuses.
But the fact is food,
if you're a woman--
at least, it was in my culture--
oh, don't eat it.
You'll get fat.
Right?
JAN YANEHIRO: This culture too.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yeah.
Or I'm depressed.
I'm just going to
have a bag of chips.
Well, both ends don't work.
And I talk about my own journey
with the H-O-L-E's that never
get filled with food.
And then so you look at
food as your nourishment
for your spirit and body,
but not just for your body.
JAN YANEHIRO: And we've been
talking about her husband.
And Thampy is here.
And in fact, it was sort
of an arranged marriage.
Sort of.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yeah.
JAN YANEHIRO: But he was
considered the most eligible
bachelor back in her home state.
And he was studying
here at Stanford.
And she thought, oh well.
I mean, her family said,
oh, you've got to marry him.
And you didn't quite
have that idea.
DEEPA THOMAS: No.
JAN YANEHIRO: And I say
this because she has helped
have him get his health back.
They have two
children, two sons.
And her son is here.
He's one of the reasons why
we are all here because he
works here at Google.
DEEPA THOMAS: Uh-huh.
Suneil Thomas.
JAN YANEHIRO: So you know, this
is a family affair right here.
So I just want to digress
just a little bit about this
and then just say--
this is a reporter question.
Both you and your
husband are immigrants.
So this is slightly
off topic from food,
but you both are immigrants.
You both became huge successes
here, raised your family here,
your children.
What do you feel about the
immigrants in America today
and what should happen?
So this is a political question.
Forgive me.
I'm a reporter.
DEEPA THOMAS: She's
going off book.
JAN YANEHIRO: Off book, but
we'll come back to the book.
So what do you think?
Well, you know, one has to
look at a personal journey,
and times have changed.
When Thampy and I
came here, I think
Suneil will attest to this--
by the time we had Suneil,
he was the first Indian
in all of the Portola Valley
schools, which is unbelievable.
You see him sitting there.
He's not that old.
He is rudely very old.
So things have changed.
And the understanding
of ethnic difference--
what has happened to the
American economy and how the 1%
is literally--
and we probably are in the 1%.
So I can say this today--
when we came here, Thampy
was making $300 a month
assistantship at Stanford
doing his PhD.
Try living on $300.
Well, I spent $50
on a straw hat.
So that took care
of the first month.
You know, we had to learn.
But here we are.
The minute we became
successful, you
have this need to hold
that door open for others.
So I don't know when you
want to talk about this, Jan,
I think I'd like to
talk through FoodCorps,
the reason I got involved.
This entire book and
all of my royalty
will go to a nonprofit
called FoodCorps.
And why?
Because my American
friends who grew up
being told to finish
what's on their plate
because there are
kids starving in India
fall off their chairs
when I tell them
that one out of five
kids in American schools
is going to bed hungry
and waking up hungry.
It is just not OK.
It's not a political thing.
So when I met Kurt Ellis--
that's a longer story-- but
he's written the forward
to my book--
he is the founding
CEO of FoodCorps--
I found a new hero.
This young man came
out of Yale and figured
out how to create a
scalable nonprofit which
goes into the schools and
works with the schools,
especially in
underprivileged areas,
to do something about
the lunch programs
and connect the kids
to healthy food habits.
So I think the immigrant story
is one of desperately trying
to succeed, and then some
of us are fortunate enough
to make it and ask the
question, how much is enough?
How much money?
How much food?
And when you answer
that question,
you hold the door
open for others.
And if you want to get into
all the politics of today,
I think it's ridiculous.
But the fact is we're individual
human beings all aspiring to be
successful, and I'd like
to stay with that thought
of philanthropy and immigrants.
It's a new story, I think,
because philanthropy was always
part of the American history.
But for immigrants,
it's sort of a luxury
to even think about
it, and we might
be on the first wave of it.
So I'm proud of that.
JAN YANEHIRO: And we are too.
So the proceeds from this
book will go to FoodCorps.
DEEPA THOMAS: My royalties.
JAN YANEHIRO: Deepa's royalties.
And for that, I think
we need to-- yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
JAN YANEHIRO: So I do
want to open up for Q&A
and leave you a lot
of time for that.
And we've got Chef
Dina here and her team.
So I'm going to
say, Dina, you're
first up for the questions.
So let's give Dina a microphone.
And we want to ask everybody
else to chime in too.
So Dina, thank you for
preparing today's menu.
CHEF DINA: Oh, it was my
pleasure, but thank you.
JAN YANEHIRO: What would
you like to ask Deepa?
JAN YANEHIRO: I wondering
what really brought you
into the idea of
writing this book?
What was your inspiration
for really spreading?
DEEPA THOMAS: That's a
very good question, Dina.
It took five years.
And I tried to say, no.
No.
It's not me.
And this is not
what I want to do.
And to the first order, I
wanted to document my recipes
for my sons because both
of them like to cook.
And it was really a dear friend
of mine who is Susan Dreyfus,
and she's in this
book as a chapter.
Susan is an award winning Oscar
nominated documentary filmmaker
it turns out.
But that aside, she and I served
on the Board of Rhode Island
School of Design together,
and we became good friends.
And it was Susan,
who in her kitchen--
and she hates to cook, but she
had a really beautiful kitchen
in New York--
she turned an
imaginary lens onto me
and said, what was your
first memory with food?
And out came tumbling my
story of my grandmother
who's in this book.
And she said, freeze the frame.
I said, I beg your pardon.
And she said, write it
the way you said it.
Because if you connect
your life stories
and how improbable it was that
you would write a cookbook--
but if you write those stories,
maybe the people who read it
will not be intimidated
by the recipes
that, yes, I've simplified it.
I've have taken the
labor out of it.
I've tried to Americanize
the understanding
of the ingredients and process.
But the real impetus was what--
it was so shocking that
five days of an accidental
turn in Thampy's life,
my husband's life,
where he forgot to take
his insulin shot, which
was grounds for panic in our
household back in the day.
But when he took his blood
sugar after five days
of eating this way, his
blood sugar was normal.
So we-- our last
name is Thomas--
so Doubting Thomases
ran off to Walgreens
and got another monitor,
and it remained normal.
So then I told my
general physician
who is the associate
dean of UCSF,
and he said, Mrs.
Thomas, you better
come in tell us
what you're doing
because there are three million
Indians in America alone
and 50% are diabetic.
India is the diabetic
capital of the world.
One third of the adult
population of America
is fighting obesity
or diabetes or both.
It's related.
So I felt if I was
going to do this then
this is going to be my gift.
And now our other
son, he and his wife
had our first grandchild.
And so of course it is
a gift to her, I hope,
that to write the course--
you know, there's been so
many challenges in life.
We all have them.
But how we overcome them.
And did I think I'd
write a cookbook?
No.
But that it sold 10,000
copies in three months,
they tell me is something good.
JAN YANEHIRO: It is good.
It's fabulous.
DEEPA THOMAS: Thank you.
JAN YANEHIRO: And we want to
say that Thampy, her husband,
is still off of insulin.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yes.
Six years and counting.
JAN YANEHIRO: Six
years and counting.
And ever since he started to--
because Deepa has
secrets in this book.
So ladies, you're
part of the crew here
that prepare healthy foods
for all the Google employees.
Questions from you.
Want to pass the mic down.
AUDIENCE: So I was
actually curious
about how different the
cuisine in your book
is from what I would consider
modern or typical Indian food.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yeah.
JAN YANEHIRO: OK.
Good question.
DEEPA THOMAS: Great question.
JAN YANEHIRO: Deepa.
DEEPA THOMAS: You know,
it's really my commitment
to art and flavor
brought together.
Now, traditional Indian food--
I promised someone earlier
I wouldn't say risks
being fifty shades of
brown, but I'm sorry folks.
Pay attention to how it
looks when it's plated
is not the first thing you
think about with Indian food.
For me, it's essential.
You know, my environment
is important.
It affects my well-being, that
there's a candle on the table.
There's maybe some fresh
flowers, even weeds.
You know, the thoughtfulness
which really help the healing
that I had to go through
in my American life,
I found that no matter
what difficulties
I was facing, if I just made
my environment a little tidier
or prettier or
maybe it's just me,
but there's a part
that I actually
write about the things we can
do to be a little more mindful.
JAN YANEHIRO: Go ahead.
DEEPA THOMAS:
First of all, which
cookbook author gets read?
But I suggest no
carb comfort foods.
Make something more beautiful.
A plate, a table,
your nightstand,
light candles in the
bedroom, window at dawn,
at the dinner table in the
back, linger after a meal.
And it's just a little--
you might see it on page two
or one--
suggestions of how to
bring up well-being.
And this was my approach
to the whole of this book,
and Indian food
suffers sometimes
from lack of thoughtfulness.
The flavor is overwhelmingly
either beautiful or spicy,
and you eat it.
And that's it.
But to take the time to
present an ancient cuisine that
has health benefits
and is beautiful.
I mean, this was--
when Sherry Heck, the
photographer in my kitchen,
saw what I was putting out
for one of the recipes,
she said, stop.
Let me take a picture of that.
So this was that shot.
I put this nutmeg with
the mace around it,
is from my husband's younger
brother's backyard in Kerala.
So I had just thrown it
on the cutting board,
and we took a shot of it.
It's that beautiful.
So why wouldn't
we lead with that?
JAN YANEHIRO: Right.
So it is beautiful.
Maybe you can talk about some
of the other spices on the book.
So the nutmeg.
And then we've got--
DEEPA THOMAS: Well, if you
start from the center out,
most of the spice
wars were fought
over this little
creature called a cloves.
JAN YANEHIRO: Which is--
DEEPA THOMAS: Right
in the middle,
and it's that
long-ish right there.
Right there.
JAN YANEHIRO: OK.
DEEPA THOMAS: And
then this is cardamom.
So clove and
cardamon and cinnamon
were the lead reasons why
trading with the South of India
was so through all the ages.
And we feel that even
during the biblical times,
St. Thomas came to
the south of India--
our church that we
belong to, Thampy and I,
dates back to St. Thomas was
martyred in Kerala apparently.
So you go on with--
I'd like to talk about this
actual spice in the background.
We think curry powder is
an Indian spice blend.
It is not.
It is a signature blend that
every housewife would make up
in her kitchen, and every mix
would be slightly different.
And then the Brits
happened in India.
And so they created
this thing called
curry powder, which can
be quite nauseating I
find in the stores.
And that's the other thing.
If you have spices
in your kitchen
that have been there for more
than six months, throw it out.
I had stuff when we
moved from years,
and I thought, oh my god.
So all the nutritional
value is gone.
It smells and
tastes like sawdust.
It is important to
keep whole spices.
So that spice there is powdered.
And of course, it
includes turmeric,
which gives that the yellow.
But it would have coriander
seeds, cumin seeds, anise seed,
fennel seed.
And if you kept seeds in your
kitchen, you can toast them up
and grind them and
that is much better way
to go than have ground spices.
And I give you recipes for
my curry blend and also
Deepa's secret spice,
which someday I
hope to productize because
then I can help more kids.
But it's 16 different spices
toasted and ground up,
and a pinch of it will make
your omelet taste one way.
And three tablespoons of it will
take your roast another way.
The recipe's in
the book as well.
JAN YANEHIRO: So does
that answer your question?
Yes.
And do you have
another question here?
You also work in
food service here.
So tell us your question.
AUDIENCE: So you had so
much success with your book.
What's next for Deepa Thomas?
JAN YANEHIRO: All right.
Good question!
DEEPA THOMAS: Tell me your name.
AUDIENCE: Jessenia.
DEEPA THOMAS: Jessenia?
What a beautiful name.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEEPA THOMAS: That's a
great question, Jessenia.
I think you and I have
to have coffee some day
and talk about it some more.
You know, every day
is an opportunity.
And just having become a
grandmother, I'm besot.
but with this little
creature that something
will happen in this journey
that is taking another turn yet.
I never thought a grandchild
could change how I view life.
It is completely different.
Every window that was close in
my spirit has been blown open.
So now the possibilities
are endless.
I think the universe
is abundant.
And I was saying earlier I
find if I leave my hands open,
as in my mind, incredible
opportunity comes my way.
So I'd love to do a line of
products that makes it easier
for the home chef.
And that to hopefully then
the sales of that will help
us do even more good work, and
I think my cause will always
be child related.
It is unconscionable, as
I said, that our children
are required to suffer in
a country that throws away
40% of its food.
I think we all should
be obsessed with this.
AUDIENCE: So
something we've talked
about is the disconnect
between where food comes from
and how it's produced and
what we actually consume.
And growing up, having
servants prepare for you
and then in the
United States maybe
having fast food
when you're young,
how did your thinking
and reaction to food
change once you started
preparing it for yourself
and understanding recipes?
DEEPA THOMAS: Oh wow.
That's a great question.
JAN YANEHIRO: But if you
read the book-- and I have--
I'm going to admit
this for Deepa.
She came to US, and they did
order pizza and Kentucky Fried
Chicken and all those things.
And she actually learned
to cook here in USA.
So there's a lead.
DEEPA THOMAS: There is.
And I think your question
is how do I view it now
that I'm more conscious
about how I shop,
what I keep in the fridge,
what I have in my pantry,
and there's a whole
chapter dedicated to that.
From my own knowledge of
if you come home tired,
I can't imagine you guys
going home and deciding
to cook for yourself.
It was a big challenge for
me when the kids were young
and I was running
my own business.
Now therefore, I've given
a cheat list of things
to keep on hand so you
can whip up a meal,
even if you don't
go grocery shopping.
So that's the first thing, to
get a little bit organized.
And I love and I'm obsessed
with farmer's markets.
So whenever I get a
chance on a Saturday
go down to the
[INAUDIBLE] building
and elbow out the chefs
who are also shopping.
JAN YANEHIRO: Dina, maybe you.
DEEPA THOMAS: And so living
in California, we have access
to such incredible ingredients.
I've been known to go a bit
crazy over specialty salts,
but I collect things that catch
my attention, a beautiful fruit
vinegar.
I know someday I'll use
it in a salad dressing
or in a marinade.
So I'm looking at
the ingredients
from a sustainable
standpoint, whether it is just
the two of us eating
or friends drop by
or it's a big party suddenly.
Will I be able to whip it
up without going berserk?
Which is another thing.
The more organized
I am, the less crazy
I get with guests,
which I've been
known to be extremely crazy.
But my whole theory is if I can
do this, anyone can do this.
That's what I'm trying
to do with this book.
It isn't a Michelin star chef--
well, somebody wrote
on the back of my book.
He happens to be a
Michelin star chef.
But for me, I wanted
to take the mystery out
of everyday cooking.
JAN YANEHIRO: And by the
way, if you're lucky enough
to be invited,
Justin, to her home,
may I just say
it's a real treat.
We enjoyed a fabulous dinner.
She had lamb chops,
and she had eggplant
with corn and a fresh salad.
If you're lucky
enough, anybody here.
Maybe we could do a
drawing or something.
So thank you for your question.
Questions on that end.
AUDIENCE: Do you
teach cooking classes?
JAN YANEHIRO: Do you teach?
AUDIENCE: Or would you like to.
DEEPA THOMAS: That's a
very good question as well.
I've barely finished this thing.
And in fact, Jan's daughter
Jenna who works with--
JAN YANEHIRO: Food Network.
DEEPA THOMAS: Yeah.
I mean, I'm really
well-connected you can tell.
So Jenna who is
adorable, she and I
were talking about maybe doing
little clips on as simple
as how do you peel a mango.
I mean, there's a
mango salad here.
Well, maybe somebody doesn't
know how to peel a mango--
a 30 second clip of that and
then eventually leading into--
I don't think I'll do
full-on cooking lessons,
but there's a way to
draw in small groups who
have specific questions or
come to places like this
and have a little, I don't know,
prepare lunch session together
and share ideas and knowledge.
I'd love to do
that kind of thing.
JAN YANEHIRO: And we
also know, because there
are a lot of millennials in this
room, you all want very quick,
short videos.
You don't want to stay for
the hour long documentary
on the history of spices.
So that's the idea that it's
going to be short clips,
and you can find it on
YouTube and learn and do it
really quickly.
AUDIENCE: What
would your advice be
to someone who is
somewhat intimidated
by the complexities
of Indian food,
who doesn't have
much time, who is--
I'm a little older than
the millennial age--
but at the same time want to
prepare dishes, meals quickly?
And where would you start?
How would you approach
it if you've never
cooked Indian food?
DEEPA THOMAS: Oh, that's
a terrific question.
And then this is spot on
because I was that person.
I didn't know how to cook.
I scorched my first meal.
And there weren't great teachers
who could have taught me.
What I remembered of my
grandmother and mother's
cooking informed me.
And I think I'd say,
approach Indian food--
now, do you cook generally?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DEEPA THOMAS: Fabulous.
Start there.
Approach it with
the comfort you have
cooking the foods you know
how to cook because that's how
I approached Indian cuisine.
I brought in the techniques
from other cuisines
that I was familiar with.
And you can open up the
earlier pages of the book
and look at the recipes.
They're really the ABC's.
I recommend very
strongly, especially
with the focus of type 2
diabetes and just losing
weight and being healthy,
a protein breakfast.
So I say, for instance, a stir
fry or a grilled vegetable
from the previous night
and I break an egg open
in a pan with onions under
it so it caramelizes it
as it's cooking and
then put it on top
of the stirred vegetables.
That's Indian food also.
So now if you want to get into
a little more complicated stuff
I've got, for
instance, I think one
of Suneil's favorite things,
the new Indian cacciatore,
the chicken dish,
which is really
reminiscent of the
Italian technique.
But there's just enough
Indian flavor and twist
to keep it familiar.
So pick the recipes,
I would say.
And if you're not going to
have this book, approach
Indian food from your comfort
level, not what you don't know.
I mean, throw in some spice.
How bad can it be?
Toasting cumin seeds-- if
there's one thing people
will try.
Toast the cumin seeds until
it's got this nutty flavor
and short of going
black and burnt.
So really a good
cinnamon char on it.
And then when it's cool, powder
it and sprinkle it on stuff.
I mean, make up your
own Indian recipes.
I want to encourage
people to go off
because I learned exactly the
way you're asking the question.
What is Indian food?
Oh, my god.
Where are the servants?
JAN YANEHIRO: I'm
ringing the bell.
So let's pass it around.
Suneil, do you have a
question for your mother?
SUNEIL THOMAS: Yeah.
I guess my question
to you is that I think
it's so important to
get people to have
a new view on Indian
food in the US,
but I think it's also
important for Indians in India
to rediscover Indian food and
have a pride in their food
and not identify luxury and a
big night out with crappy food.
And do you have any
plans around that?
DEEPA THOMAS: That's a
great question, Suneil.
I can see you're
creating work for me.
JAN YANEHIRO: As
a good son should.
DEEPA THOMAS: As
But that is a big challenge.
At the moment, the book is
only sold in the US and Canada.
But of course,
Amazon is everywhere.
And so it's amazing
how much demand
has been created in India
for this kind of cooking.
Now, what you're talking
about is a mindset,
how we view comfort food.
And what's the
need for comfort--
what do we call comfort food?
The foods you're describing--
it's after a long day,
let's go have some drinks
and eat rubbish is the way to
mitigate the stress that we
probably should have
handled in a different way
in the first place.
I don't think it's
just India, but it's
all countries that
are struggling
with stress of
economic competition
and the fear of loss--
loss of a job, loss of
well-being, whatever it is.
I don't think any one person can
change the ethos of a culture
like India or America or
any country, but all of us
together can ask the
question of ourselves.
What are the tools we
have to handle threats?
Simple question.
I had the worst.
In fact, I didn't
have any tools.
Today I have a few more tools.
And as I have more
tools to handle stress,
I pay more attention.
I'm more mindful.
So until we as ordinary
citizens get mindful,
I don't think brands
or anyone else
is going to stop selling to--
it's like drugs.
Why do people buy drugs?
They think it'll make
them feel better.
Same thing-- junk
food and drugs are
in the same area of the brain.
Sugar is registered in exactly
the same place in the brain
that cocaine is processed.
Now we can go into neurology and
talk about the power of food.
But I think it's an
ongoing discussion, Suneil,
and I'm getting
into this process
where there's a professor at
Stanford who is addressing
diabetes in India.
And he's just asked
me to come over,
and we'll see where it goes.
Anything to help.
JAN YANEHIRO: Right.
I could see it,
books all over India,
Deepa's books all over India.
And I think that people would
discover the healthful benefits
and really use this.
AUDIENCE: I think of
myself, and I cook
and I'm willing to
try some of the dishes
that you would have
highlighted, but then I
think back to my parents
who still live in India.
And they're used to their
style of cooking and eating.
I wonder if you have thoughts
on how I can sort of introduce
them to thinking about
food differently and sort
of adapting to this
style of cooking.
DEEPA THOMAS: Where
are they in India?
AUDIENCE: They're
in Maharashtra.
DEEPA THOMAS: OK.
Then that's good because
Maharashtra has healthier food,
I have to say, than several
of the Northern states.
And the reason I
ask that is I don't
think you can change their
perspective until they
feel a need to be healthier.
Are they in good health?
AUDIENCE: Yes, so
far they're doing--
DEEPA THOMAS: OK.
Well, then I wouldn't
mess with it.
They probably
don't need my book.
But the attitudes change
from, if you're curious,
as to what foods
cause inflammation.
So say you meet
somebody with arthritis.
That's inflammation,
and it's food based.
So you can go to
a Western doctor
and get medication,
which will guaranteed
make your gut bacteria die.
So it's up to us to be curious,
and of all the places, Google.
Come on guys.
You can get all
the information you
need on how foods
affect inflammation
and what are the foods
that reduce inflammation.
Just even having a
discussion on how they feel.
Fatigue is a form
of inflammation.
So I entered this arena
through that standpoint.
I'm one of the
lucky human beings,
apparently in the
1% of my age group,
100 years old, who is
on zero medication.
Now that's something to be in
a family with heart disease
and diabetes that I
come from, I think
it has something to do
with paying attention
to what goes in my mouth.
And I'm not a good--
I do all the wrong things, but
there's recovery to be had.
Your body is dying to heal.
It literally is dying to heal.
So if you will help
it, it will heal.
JAN YANEHIRO: If you can turn
to two recipes in the book that
you would say are your favorites
or maybe Thampy's favorite
or Suneil's favorite, what
recipe would you say--
so for all of you who would
like to see the book--
what page would you say?
Turn to this page.
This is my favorite
dish, my favorite recipe
or Thampy's favorite.
What would you say?
DEEPA THOMAS: OK.
First of all, it's like asking
me to choose a favorite child.
JAN YANEHIRO: I know, but--
DEEPA THOMAS: And he's
sitting right there
because he showed up.
OK.
How many eat fish or
meat in this room?
JAN YANEHIRO: OK.
And there are a
couple of vegetarians.
Bihan is a vegetarian.
Any other vegetarians?
Oh.
Two.
Three.
Three vegetarians.
DEEPA THOMAS: So
let me start with--
you gave me two, right?
JAN YANEHIRO: Yes, two.
DEEPA THOMAS: OK.
Perhaps my favorite vegetable--
funny thing-- is cabbage.
And maybe because it was cooked
so badly in India, cooked
within one inch of death.
JAN YANEHIRO: Bihan is not in
his name, in his head rather.
DEEPA THOMAS: And the stink.
I mean, you came in the
house, and you could smell it.
So I went on this tear to make
it more crunchy and salad-like
and yet flavorful.
So I would say Hot and
Crispy Cabbage on page 150.
JAN YANEHIRO: OK.
So we are going to turn to 150.
DEEPA THOMAS: Gosh, you're
really going to do this.
JAN YANEHIRO: Absolutely.
Here we go.
Yes.
Here it is.
OK.
So the vegetarians in the
room, three of you, this
is your page.
Page 150.
DEEPA THOMAS: What's up on
top is yet another recipe,
Spicy Peanuts, which is one of
Suneil's favorites as a snack.
And it's the kind of snack
I keep on hand at home
so that we are eating smaller
meals, four to five meals.
Not three large ones
or two gigantic ones.
And if you get
hungry, a quarter cup
of these spicy peanuts
or the [INAUDIBLE] nuts
will absolutely curb
the hunger back.
And it's amazing.
I like to say that
the stomach is not
behind the bellybutton, folks.
It's a little higher.
So you get full really easily.
And paying attention to how much
food is going into this-- this
is the size of a
stomach, the fist.
It should be.
It should remain that way.
But as we get older, it's not.
So, yes.
I would say that's one
of the favorite recipes.
JAN YANEHIRO: OK.
And for the folks
in the audience,
they eat fish and meat,
what would you say?
DEEPA THOMAS: Oh.
I have to pick the Clay Pot
Fish, and that is page 164.
And you don't need
a clay pot for this
even though it's
called Clay Pot.
It's such a simple
coconut sauce that if you
can nail this one, which
is very easy to make,
then you might even throw
in roasted vegetables
into the coconut sauce.
So it's very versatile.
I encourage people
to go off book
because these sauces
and techniques,
you can use whatever
ingredients you want.
There's a mughlai
sauce in the book--
which mughlai sauce typically
is cream based and very heavy
and you need a wheelbarrow
to leave the restaurant.
But this is made, I substituted
coconut milk for the cream.
And you can keep it
on hand in your fridge
and come home and put
anything into that thing.
It'll make shoe
leather taste good.
JAN YANEHIRO: So there are
two tips from the book itself.
So in closing,
what would you like
to say to this audience
about "Deepa's Secret?"
What is the biggest secret
you have, number one?
And what's the message you
want to give to everybody here
in this audience and to
all the Google campuses?
DEEPA THOMAS: Well
first of all, a huge
thank you to all of you for
taking the time to be here
and to the wonderful culinary
team that has prepared
so many recipes from my book.
JAN YANEHIRO: Yeah.
Give it up for them
They worked today.
DEEPA THOMAS: And so we're
going to try some of that stuff.
But really my request is
to be mindful around food.
It took me a great deal
of time to really focus
on what that means.
And the more I
stabilize my spirit,
the better my cooking
got, funny thing.
So does that make sense?
I hope it does.
And so I'm sure you'll
all in your busy lives
figure out oasis.
Make cooking a zen
experience, not a frenetic
get food on the table exercise.
If you're just using half an
hour of your time to cook,
put the music on.
Pour yourself a glass of wine.
Play some music.
And get into the zone.
And have fun with it.
JAN YANEHIRO: So there you go.
Everybody, Deepa Thomas,
"Deepa's Secrets."
Again, I'm here because
Deepa is donating
her royalties to FoodCorps,
and I think that is important.
So thank you all for coming.
DEEPA THOMAS: Can I tell a
quick story just two seconds.
JAN YANEHIRO: OK, yes.
DEEPA THOMAS: How I met Jan.
I was buying a card at
Papyrus, and the manager there
had bought my book.
And she texted me and
said, would you sign it.
I said, oh, I'm right next door.
I'll just walk over and sign it.
So I walk in.
And she's a little excitable.
So she started
jumping up and down
that I'd physically present--
I started jumping up and down.
And we didn't know that there
was somebody at the counter,
and I looked over and said.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
And I said, are
you Jan Yanehiro?
And she said, yes I am.
JAN YANEHIRO: It's me.
It's me.
DEEPA THOMAS: And that
was just a few weeks ago.
Can you imagine?
And we've become
like soul sisters.
And here she is
supporting my journey.
JAN YANEHIRO: And she asked me
to come and do this interview.
DEEPA THOMAS: From
Jackie Speier who you
were interviewing two days ago.
JAN YANEHIRO: On Monday.
DEEPA THOMAS: To this.
Am I lucky?
JAN YANEHIRO: So thank
you all for joining us.
I think there's some
great secrets in this book
that we can all learn from.
Thank you for having us
here at the Google campus.
I was excited coming to Google.
I'm bragging.
I'm going to Google.
I'm going to go to Google.
I'm going to have
lunch at Google.
So thank you for having us.
Thank you Deepa for
creating this book.
One more time, thank
you to Deepa, everybody.
DEEPA THOMAS: Oh, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]